no one person can make a great video
game but there are certain people in the
industry whose reputation precedes them
we spawn an infinity ward co-founder
Vincent Pella is one such individual a
man largely responsible for making one
of the most popular video games of all
time but such praise can be as much a
curse as it is a blessing when you're
trying to make something new i sat down
with Vince asked him about life after
call of duty and his four-year journey
making titanfall Vincent petticoat
founded infinity ward with jason west
and grant collie a in 2002 and went on
to reinvent first person online
multiplayer with the call of duty
franchise however in March 2010 himself
and West were dramatically fired by
Activision after allegations of contract
breaches an allegation that would
eventually be contested by the parent
court and results of Activision paying
out an undisclosed settlement in the
months that followed nearly half of the
team at infinity ward resigned a total
of forty-six many of whom were tough to
your developers and programmers who had
worked on modern warfare 2 the vast
majority of these men and women went on
to joins on pelham West at their new
studio quite appropriately named respawn
entertainment it's not the type of story
you hear very often a large group of
people leaving a successful company to
work with their former boss somewhere
else so what is it about Vincent para
and the games he makes well on the eve
of the titanfall beta launch I had the
opportunity to talk to the man and first
I asked him after years of working on
call of duty was his goal always to make
something new and once that game always
titanfall it took a while to get kind of
situated and get our flow down then we
started with different ideas you know
and there was it wasn't just like yes
we're making titanfall there was a lot
of ideas thrown out under the table we
wanted to break the boundaries when I'm
not making it completely different it's
familiar it feels like you know if you
played a footm acute ER game before you
can sit down you can grasp the controls
you know what you're doing I'd done
sequels for a while so this was more
about you know taking it to another
level doing
a little different so what is that
something new when you look at titanfall
at least on a surface level it doesn't
seem that different to other
first-person shooters it has people with
guns and buildings and customizable
Odette's player leveling it's not until
you pledge that the differences become
apparent Vince told me that the recent
beta was not only a way of stress
testing the game and getting feedback
but also a way of getting tight and fall
into people's hands so they can see what
makes it different something they've
always been keen to do you know I think
we've let people play it so there is no
you know hey I think it's gonna be good
it's I plated I touched it and I think
it's good like we know for our fans to
go out there and say that you know if I
don't know what better praise you can
get though not often is touted as other
Fame developers the name Vince Zampella
carries a lot of weight especially in
light of how Respawn Entertainment came
to be so I asked him in light of his
previous achievements how much personal
pressure did he have going into this
project I think we put a lot of pressure
on ourselves just as a team to really
make something that's the best we can
possibly do on top of that you know
there is the you want to prove like okay
you know we can do this again you know
just even for our own personal
satisfaction of you know we want to do
something good we were in games because
we love it it's just it's what we do
it's in our DNA so it's that you know it
has to be good for that reason and then
unveiling the game and having it be
received so well and it's you know it
adds another level of pressure it's like
well we have to deliver you know we've
got to deliver a multi promise it seemed
anytime I asked Vince a question about
himself he'd respond with we instead of
I as if tried to downplay his individual
importance I asked him why he and
development is a team sport you know
it's this game wouldn't exist as it is
without everybody on this team so I mean
to me it is natural it's not me I didn't
make thank you from respondent respawn
is a team of people that you know some
of us have worked together for a long
time other people are new and they've
come in and they've changed the mix and
they've been energized us and you know
so it is it's all about the team perhaps
that's the Zampella formula having a
team of people around you you can
and on a team willing to leave their
jobs or join a fledgling studio to try
and make something new and interesting
lastly just mere weeks away from the
launch of a game has been working on for
four years I asked Vince what the future
held for himself respawn I'm titanfall
it's been a long kind of road to get
where we are there's been you know a
long bumpy road to you know so to be
where we are to rally the team together
get through all the adversity that we
faced and get to a point where we're
releasing something that you know we're
proud of and as being so just it's being
accepted by the fans and by everyone you
know just so well it means a lot it's it
feels good and that wraps up the next
big game titanfall for continuing
coverage of the game including its
review once it drops in March make sure
to visit gamespot com thanks very much
for joining us all this week folks we'll
see you next time
that's a streak